hey you guys
movie retrospective time one that jenny
is really really really excited about
finally i'm finally getting her out of
doing a racer head
i waited so long look tom got me this
for christmas the criterion collection
yep and i just like been waiting i kept
putting it in the poll
it's got a big book and everything i
know there's like a 60 something page
book in there about it
it's like there's all kind of extras on
it that's awesome but um yeah so i kept
putting it in the poll like for the
movie retrospective and it never got
uh the most votes and i was just kind of
like god damn it and then finally i said
okay i'm gonna put it in there one more
time
if it doesn't win the poll this time
then i'm just gonna do it by myself like
on my
next uh you know in the movie uh
thing that i'm starting next month but
finally finally you guys picked it so
i'm very very excited to finally be
talking about eraserhead because i feel
like i don't do enough david lynch on
this show
i think i did i did mulholland drive but
i think i did that one by myself because
that's when you were in uh mississippi
but yeah so eraserhead probably i mean
one of the cult movies of cult movies of
all time really it's kind of like
there was like a big retrospective of um
i think it's a big book or something
like that talking about
the midnight movie phenomenon you know
like in the 70s and 80s where
movies would show every night or every
weekend night and people would come out
in the middle of the night to see them
and um it kind of talked about the six
uh you know most classic most famous uh
midnight movies of which eraserhead was
one obviously rocky where a picture
shows in there pink flamingos
you know john waters and i think el topo
was one of them the harder they come
and i can't remember what the other one
was but yeah so this hasn't been dead
one in there
yeah night of living dead was in there
and i think there was one more but i
can't remember what it was
but yeah so this is kind of like this is
one of those movies it came out in 1977
and it first played in theaters i think
when it premiered
um you know it didn't have a wide
release or anything like that because i
mean david lynch this is his first
full-length feature film he'd made like
several um you know shorts before this
but he was still
a film student when he first started
working on this
you know he was in his early 20s and so
it got kind of a limited release i think
the first
the first showing it had in uh i guess
it was in la or whatever
i think there was like 20 people like in
the first screening
and it really didn't find its audience
until it went on the midnight movie
circuit and people kept going back and
seeing it
over and over again trying to figure it
out and then it just got all this word
of mouth like you have to see this
[ __ ] weird ass movie
and uh so then it just kind of like the
cult of it grew out from then
and it's weird because eraserhead was
his first full-length movie right
and then because of the word of mouth
about it
and the buzz that it got that one got
him his second movie which was
an elephant man right because mel brooks
ended up seeing
uh eraserhead and like was really
impressed with it and
they you know they so they were trying
to like work with david lynch stanley
kubrick
uh before he was making the shining he
told david lynch this is my favorite
film of all time and apparently he
showed a racer head to the cast and crew
of the shining to like
this is the vibe that i want to get like
in this movie this is like a massively
massively
influential movie um you know it's
particularly it's like surrealism it's
sound design is probably the most
uh you know the most influential thing
because that
it was something that a lot of films
didn't do
back then i think david lynch was really
kind of like a pioneer in these like
bizarre ass like [ __ ]
uh kind of oral soundscapes like to try
to
convey a certain sense of dread or this
kind of overwhelming kind of [ __ ]
so all right so i know like david lynch
is very love it or hate it
kind of thing like you you think this
movie is just
weird and it's not you know what i'm
saying
what the movie is uh
it's a it's a weird movie about very
mundane topics and they use
i guess you could say uh absurdist
[ __ ] imagery
to take it emotionally over the top
to try to get you to feel a certain way
about this
subject this subject is basically child
rearing in a way
sort of i mean it's it's a family life
or something
yeah it's kind of like i mean at its
heart and you know
there's really no one interpretation of
any david lynch thing
it's just kind of like you see what you
want to see in it but i think that it's
very basic it's kind of not only about
somebody that is obviously not ready for
child rearing and not
ready for you know settling down into a
family life just someone who's not ready
for adulthood and the
anxieties that go along with that but
the thing about david lynch is that he
takes everything he'll take something
like that but he
he puts it on film the way it would come
about in
a dream like if you dreamed about those
anxieties that you had that's what he's
trying to capture
yeah because it because it's kind of
like an emotion that you can't really
that you can't really access or express
in your waking life i guess and like
some [ __ ] comes out
in your dreams and it doesn't seem like
it means anything but then later if you
think about it it does kind of mean
it's not a dialogue driven movie no it's
it's very imagery driven symbolism
driven
yeah uh it's kind of like naked lunch
but much weirder naked lunch had a lot
of dialogue in it to keep it going yeah
and this movie isn't very long and it
doesn't take place in very many places
it's visually pretty [ __ ] weird
especially a little kid
like what is that you know no one knows
it's a mystery
to this day i have my theories about
what it is
i think well because let's talk about
that it's a we don't
have to like talk about this in order or
anything like that because obviously
it's a razor head we're talking about
so i don't know if you guys know but
there is kind of um
the baby in a racer head uh you know the
deformed baby
it's kind of like legendary at this
point that david lynch
refuses to say how they made that
prop how they made that baby um
you know he'll just say something real
cryptic like oh it was just it was born
like near where we're filming
it or you know we just found it
somewhere or something i mean obviously
somebody made it
because it's articulated like it moves
its little eyes roll around
and everything and its mouth moves but
looks like it was made out of something
that was alive at one time i think so
too because i think in 1977 well
actually
you know this movie took like five years
like off and on to make
because of the money so it actually was
the early 70s when they first started
working on it
and it you wouldn't have got a special
effect
that good um without using some real
[ __ ]
and i suspect do you know what it
reminds me of
it reminds me of the dead rabbit
in um uh roman polanski's
repulsion like the rabbit that she's
supposed to cook
and it's like in the fridge and like as
she starts losing her marbles and like
it
starts to rot because she's just trapped
in this apartment for so long
it kind of reminds me of that so a lot
of people have said that maybe it's a
skinned rabbit or maybe it's like a lamb
fetus or maybe it's something like that
that that they stuck
looks a little bit like a fish to me
that could be too
but part fish they changed the eyes on
it
might have been like a catfish head or
something and then they
removed the lips from the catfish yeah
because they're usually on like a
membrane
and then they change the eyes and put a
different kind of eye in it
because a fish would be easy to dry out
and kind of plasticate
and preserve so it wouldn't rot i think
it's a fish maybe
yeah because you would think and i i
don't know because like i said this
movie took like five years to make
and so obviously they couldn't have this
rotting
of this whatever this was like hanging
around on the set maybe they did all
those scenes at the same time i'm not
really sure
but it's still like one of the creepiest
like special effects ever and i think
it's even more creepy just because you
don't know how the [ __ ]
they made it because it was obviously
like you said it obviously looks like
something that was alive
so uh so the story of david lynch and
like i said this is not
yes the story matters but it does have a
story it's not as
um inscrutable i guess as some people
might perceive it to be
i didn't i haven't found it all that
incredible straightforward
i thought that as well um you know so
jack nance uh obviously who worked with
david lynch a lot he was also in twin
peaks later on uh kind of he kind of had
a sad ending actually i might get into
that but
um so he plays henry spencer and he's
this dude
who lives in this kind of industrial
wasteland or something like that i'm
obviously right
uh it's actually meant to be i think
it's meant to be
uh philadelphia because i'm sorry david
lynch
um spent a lot of time when he first
married his first wife peggy
and they had had a daughter jennifer who
later became a film director in her own
right
but they had moved to philadelphia i
think david lynch is originally from
missouri but they had
moved to philadelphia they didn't have a
lot of money so they were living this
really like [ __ ]
shitty like crime-ridden neighborhood
and um so i think that informed a lot of
his earlier work
what i always thought was interesting
was i always thought that the place
that henry lives like in eraserhead i
don't even know
it's not supposed to be a specific place
because like i said it's almost like a
dream landscape but it's just like this
gritty like industrial wasteland i
almost
think that it's supposed to be like
post-apocalyptic
because in his apartment there's a
little framed picture on the wall of a
mushroom cloud
and i kind of think that they're hinting
that maybe like something has happened
but it's left non-specific because it
does really seem like a sort of
you know post-apocalyptic wasteland
looks like there's no plants or anything
so uh so yeah so he lives in this place
he works as a printer but he's quote
unquote on vacation
now he finds out he's going back to his
apartment
and the woman across the hall who
doesn't
have a name in the she's just called the
beautiful girl across the hall
she comes out and says hey that girl
that's always coming around mary she
just called and you're invited to her
parents house for dinner
um so you know they want to talk to you
so he goes over to
his girlfriend mary x's house and
it's pretty much the weirdest
meeting the parent scene ever committed
to film
it's just this really unsettling it's
just kind of like
the that's what i mean about david lynch
taking anxieties that everybody can
relate to
it's just like oh my god i'm having
dinner with the girlfriend's parents for
the first time or whatever
um but like ramping it up to this absurd
surrealist degree where it just becomes
this kind of like living nightmare i
mean the [ __ ] with like the
mini chickens you know man-made chickens
but they're new and like he cuts into
him and like blood comes out the butt of
it it's like all this other kind of [ __ ]
and then like [ __ ] his girlfriend
starts having a seizure and nobody says
anything about
it it's just like the creepiest weirdest
[ __ ] and there's like all this [ __ ]
weird ass noise and like this [ __ ]
dog is in there with all the
puppies like suckling and those
i don't know it's just like the weirdest
thing about the dad is like the with
like the grin and everything
and then so they have this horrible
nightmarish dinner
and then mary's mom is basically says
have you and mary had sexual intercourse
since they'll say he's like what the
[ __ ] that's none of your business
and then they said well there's a baby
and then mary's line there is so great
it's like they don't even know if it is
a baby
so she's in the interim between henry
and mary
because i was always of the impression
that they had kind of not broken up
but they weren't really together anymore
because when he first comes to the house
he says i haven't seen you around in a
long time or something like that
so i don't know how long it's been but
obviously
she has had this deformed baby or
whatever it is maybe it isn't a baby
in the meantime well that's what she
said she's you know they don't even know
if it is a baby
and the mom is like it's premature but
there's a baby and it's at the hospital
so it's basically she's like
well you guys have to go pick up the
baby and then you have to get married
and take care of the baby and so that's
what happens
so they all move into henry's like tiny
one-room apartment
and this monster baby is just lays on
the
dresser and it makes this horrible
horrible noise which i heard
was he um had taken he had recorded his
daughter jennifer when she was a baby
and uh used that for some i mean he
altered it and [ __ ] like that but he
altered it like to sound so it would
sound like super horrific
so so she's in there like mary's in
there and she's trying to like feed the
baby and it won't eat and it's like you
know it just keeps crying and all this
other kind of [ __ ]
and finally she's been putting up with
it for a little while and she's just
like [ __ ] this i can't take it anymore
so she leaves the baby there with henry
and henry has no [ __ ] idea how to do
anything how to take care of this baby
and then he starts like [ __ ] around
with the lady across the hall
and it's just kind of there's all this
bizarre bizarre [ __ ]
oh and also there's like this big cheek
girl that lives in his radiator
that things to him and [ __ ] like that
but like i said
it's kind of like it sounds crazy like
when you talk about it like all the
imagery and it sounds like it doesn't
mean anything and it's like oh and at
some point he has a dream where
um his head comes off and you know it
kind of goes pop and then like the
baby's head comes out
of there and then um his head like
falls through this puddle and then
a little boy picks it up and takes it to
a pencil factory and they use his head
to make erasers with hence where
the you know the title or razor head
came from
but as i said if you think about it all
of the
um imagery in this is kind of
just on that side of it i don't know
it's
like i said to me it doesn't seem all
that
strange or it doesn't seem i mean it is
strange but it doesn't seem like it's
that hard to figure out i mean obviously
you know the very beginning where you
first see
henry's head and there's like the planet
and then he has like that [ __ ] thing
like come out of his mouth like that big
long sperm creature and then it falls
into a puddle
and i mean obviously the puddle is
supposed to be the womb that's you're
showing the conception of the
of the monster baby or whatever that's
what that is
and they kind of show being born and
then
you know some some of the other stuff
like i said the woman that lives across
the hall that's just supposed to be
like his lust or his lust for freedom uh
sexual freedom because like i said this
is
you know a lot of people have made much
of the fact that
david lynch first wrote this
when um he had had him and his wife had
had
their daughter jennifer in i think 67 or
68 or something like that
david lynch was very very young um
and jennifer had uh club feet when she
was born
that needed a lot of corrective surgery
so i think that you're kind of seeing
and i'm not saying that it's just like a
one-to-one comparison of
you know the [ __ ] that baby was like his
deformed daughter because that's awful
but you can see where some of the ideas
for this came from it's like him being a
very young man
and you know suddenly his girlfriend or
his wife you know he married her at the
time they were very very young
they were both very creative they were
looking you know to
kind of further their careers and stuff
and then all of a sudden you know
they have a baby that they didn't expect
because she was an unexpected pregnancy
who has all of these medical problems
so you can see where that anxiety is
coming from
um because a lot of the imagery in it
like i said a lot of the sperm imagery
there's one uh there's one scene where
henry has this little
it's not exactly like one of the little
sperm creatures but it looks like a
little
a little worm or something like that and
he puts it
like in this box like in his apartment
and closes it all up
and i think that is meant to represent
like
that's his um you know his
sexual desire i guess and he's kind of
having to keep it locked away because
he's married now and he has a baby and
he has all these responsibilities
even though him and his wife don't
really seem to have any connection like
i said to one another um
you know they don't she yeah he's just
going through the motions because he had
to and i think that's kind of another
another thing too where the weird scene
where
they're eating dinner with the parents
and
you know the mom is like sitting there
like when henry's cutting up the chicken
and all the blood's coming out of the
chicken
and then the mom's sitting over there
like making this really weird noise and
then
her eyes roll back in her head and she
starts like drooling and [ __ ] like that
and then she runs off into the kitchen
and then mary runs off into the kitchen
and then the dad looks at henry's like
she'll be all right you know what i mean
so i think that they're kind of showing
you know you settle down with the kid
and the wife and everything like that
this is what you can look forward to
like this poor dad that's like sitting
here like pretending everything's okay
when it's not
um even though everything is just
clearly like [ __ ] off the rails
batshit crazy
but yeah also i think there's also a lot
of debate
about what the lady in the radiator
represents i've seen three or four
different interpretations and pretty
much any of them could be the case
i think that you know can there's a big
thing too it's like why does the lady
and the radiator have this big
cheeks like that now
a couple of the interpretations i've
seen and any of these could be true like
i said
i think that the lady in the radiator
having those big cheeks
either means that she is
um an almost like grotesque
it's not it's almost almost like a
grotesque kind of thing of
a smile like she has these big like
treats like she's supposed to be
um really really like overly cheerful
like to a grotesque degree
or i have seen an interpretation too
that because i kind of think that she
represents
death she's like an angel she's like an
angelic figure but i think that she
represents death because i do think that
he dies at the end
because there's one scene of her in the
radiator
um and oh and what i was going to say is
that death is supposed to be like a
as in the context of movies must be
alluring but also kind of ugly
um so i think that's kind of what they
did because she's obviously like a
really cute girl but then she has like
these really weird like big
chipmunk cheeks so they kind of made her
look grotesque but she's still cute
so but there's one scene where they show
her like on the stage and she's like
all these this the [ __ ] creatures are
like kind of raining down from the
ceiling and then she's like stepping on
them and squishing them
and like all of the you know this white
stuff that's
popping out of them and stuff so i think
that she is
in a way she's kind of saying because
her whole thing with the song
you know the song in heaven everything
is fine she's trying to convince him
that
um you know all you have to do is get
rid of that baby
and then everything will be fine and you
can come to me and
you'll be dead and all your problems
will be solved you know what i mean
so she is kind of trying to get
and i i think that he sees that that's
like the only way out
you know what i'm saying now i have seen
more i have seen more
like cheerful interpretations that maybe
she's like the embodiment
of hope um and the fact that
maybe the baby isn't even real at all
but it just kind of um
represents like his failure his anxiety
or fear about the future and him killing
the baby at the end is him getting over
it
uh getting over his fear of the future
and like him embracing her at the end is
you know saying you know the future's
gonna be bright or whatever but i i
don't know i
that it that could be but i do kind of
feel like maybe that's an overly
that's an overly happy interpretation i
i personally think that he dies at the
end
but i don't really know but like i said
it's not it you know you can argue
better all day long and people have been
since 1977
because there are so many different
interpretations of it that there's just
no way
and he's not going to say like which one
i believe this came at the same time
star wars did
yeah yeah well and i yeah and i feel
like um
some people have pointed out too that
the baby looks a lot like uh
admiral admiral ackbar yeah
so maybe a lot more people have been
influenced by this than like
than they have been but yeah so so as i
said what ended up happening with this
so david lynch was still uh like i said
a film student when he first started
working on this
now he's a big fan of um
franz kafka uh so you can see a lot of
that influence oh there's a box down
there and she's getting
she's it's that's very small pokey i
don't know if he could fit in there
you know so he's a big fan of franz
kafka and he said the metamorphosis was
like a big um
was a big influence on eraserhead also
uh a short story by nicolego nikolai
goggle
uh the nose which is which was written
back in the 19th century
and is about a dude whose nose jumps off
his face
and starts to go have like its own
little life and adventures and whatnot
so um so he said that was a big
influence too
but this wasn't actually supposed to be
his first movie he was supposed to do
one i think was called garden back
because david lynch started out as a
visual artist he's a painter
uh you know still is and so he started
out doing
films because he wanted to um
animate his paintings so a lot of his
early short films are like his paintings
but he's like animated them so they move
so he had done this painting of this
like dude he was like a hunchback and he
had like all this
um you know all these trees and plants
and [ __ ] like growing out of his back
and he wrote um a script for this
but it was only supposed to i think it
was only supposed to be like 40 it was
supposed to be 40 something minutes long
or whatever
and uh his professors they were like man
that you know for
for this idea because i think the the
germ of the idea for eraserhead was in
there because it had
a couple named henry and mary um but
theirs were about this one was about
adultery it was kind of like and it was
supposed to be like
the lust for the other women was
supposed to be right like represented by
this insect that kept getting bigger and
bigger
so that was kind of like the original
story but then they were like well you
know
the instructors were kind of like well
we don't know if this
premise can you know be sustained over
48 minutes or however long it was
supposed to be
and so there was kind of a big thing
about that and they're like why don't
you
make uh you know eraserhead instead so
we ended up making
that and um i was gonna say
so so they ended up getting some of the
funding
from the american film institute where
he was going at the time
but because it took so long to get
funding and they kept running out of
money and all this other kind of [ __ ]
um you know it took them like five years
to do it what they ended up doing this
is so funny to me this
this just goes to show how somebody like
david lynch
i was reading something earlier today
and it kind of stuck with me where
people kind of complain about not just
david lynch but anybody that makes like
experimental film or experimental art of
anyway
of any type and they're just always well
you know they're just making that to
[ __ ] with people or they're just making
that like
to troll people or as a joke like to
seem deep or whatever
but the fact that eraserhead took
five years to make that he was able to
sustain his interest
in the project over five years he
actually
um took on a paper route he delivered
the washington post
like in the middle of the night like to
help pay for this movie um
jack and he got his parents and his
wife's parents
they gave him money to help um so they
all worked on this and jack nance who
played uh henry spencer his wife
catherine e coulson his first wife uh
who most people know was uh the log lady
from twin peaks
um she worked as a she got another job
as a waitress and gave all of her tips
uh to david lynch to work on it and she
also trained um
you know on the crew like she learned
how to do a bunch of stuff around there
because
like i said no one was getting paid on
this [ __ ] so the fact that
he spent that much of his time that much
of his own money
and that a lot of the people on the crew
um
were all in for it and you know would do
it for no money
and stuck with him all of that time i
mean
obviously that means that they believed
in it they had
you know he felt like he had something
to say that he wanted to get across
um you wouldn't spend you wouldn't go to
that much trouble just to make something
to go oh look how deep i am you know
what i mean i just i just feel like that
wouldn't happen
um he really had something that he
wanted to get across but like i said
that's what i always kind of liked about
uh david lynch
very famously too jack nance and his
ridiculous hairdo in this
because this movie took so long to film
he uh
no cat butt
oh pokey look at her little butt she's
crazy i'm totally leaving that in too
we're having a surreal david lynch
moment with a cat with a cat bite in
there
yeah but yeah so uh jack nance's
ridiculous hairdo in the movie
because she's getting all bad
don't please don't don't don't don't
don't please don't please don't please
she's like what she jumped up there and
there was nowhere to go don't you want
to see it don't you want to see my butt
don't you want to see my butt oh pokey
get down off there where to go nowhere
to go
but yeah so it so his ridiculous hair so
because this movie took so long to film
he had to have his hair like that for
like six years
big because well very famously there's a
couple shots there's one shot in the
movie where
you know henry opens a door and they
said well the scene where he walks
through the door like into the room
it's like that was filmed like a year
later so the fact that
they were able to sustain such a mood
even though it took that long to film
it's like they kept running out of money
and it's like
okay we'll get more money we'll film a
little bit more on it so the fact that
it like just hangs together as well as
it does
and that nobody's like aged or anything
like that is [ __ ] crazy to me
also like i said gotta talk a little bit
about the sound design
which is as much a part of this movie as
any of the characters the visuals even
david lynch kind of known he's very very
into the use of sound to like evoke
moods particularly dread um you know so
so he was one of the first to kind of
pioneer that sort of like we're gonna
put like all this
uh you know dread inducing like uh
industrial noise like it
soundscapes like in the background he
was one of the first people to do that
um also another i i guess it's not such
a fun fact
but the dude that composed the
in heaven song the lady in the radiator
song peter ivers
he was actually murdered and his murder
is not solved
because i actually wrote about it in one
of my books
so in case you didn't know and also
another sad uh fact is that jack nance
who played henry he actually died
when he got into a fist fight with
somebody in front of a winchell's donut
shop
about what i don't know he said later oh
yeah i guess i deserved it um
he was hanging out with friends later
that day and he had like a shiner like a
black eye
and then apparently they found him dead
later on like laying on a bathroom floor
or something like that he'd have all
kind of internal injuries and he didn't
know about it
so yeah he just he got he got killed
like in front of a [ __ ] isn't that
[ __ ] sad i don't know that's really
sad to me
but yeah so as i said um you know we
don't
we don't do a lot of david lynch on here
unfortunately because i still do want to
do
um [ __ ] man i got twin peaks firewalk
with me i got to do
the whole entire twin peak series which
i'm going to do as soon as i
watch all of them i'm going to sit down
and watch them all i've seen the first
two seasons but i still haven't seen the
third one because
i just haven't had time to sit down and
watch them but i'll probably do that for
my
new movie review show but i definitely
want to do a racer head because i got it
for
christmas and it's probably one of my
favorite experimental
uh movies ever made and like i said it's
not
you know if you haven't seen it it
sounds crazy like when you're telling
people what actually happens in it
um but it's pretty i don't know i just i
just feel like it's pretty
straightforward like the imagery if you
think about it for a few minutes it's
pretty straightforward
even the stuff about like the whole
dream sequence where his head pops off
and the kid finds it and takes it to the
pencil factory and they take this stuff
out of his head and make
pencil erasers out of it i mean to me
that seems like
that's kind of like a metaphor for him
wanting to erase the baby
like he wanted to go back to before that
had happened you know what i mean
because there was a whole thing where
they take the pencil out with the new
eraser on it
the guy draws a line and then erases the
the line
and then he says oh it's pretty good
like it's or it's okay so
he's just trying to say i wanted to go
back to before that happened he wanted
to erase
the baby from existence um i mean i
thought
that's what that was saying maybe i
don't know your mileage may vary
but uh yeah so this is a baby
or does it symbolize something else um
it's both or either
um i've it could be a baby um
in in a literal sense that
the mom says they're not sure it's a
baby yeah she yeah she's like they're
not sure it even is a baby
yeah um it stands for something else
it's got to
well as i said i've seen some
interpretations that say that it could
just stand for
henry's anxiety that he's not ready for
adulthood or he's not ready for
responsibility
and that's just an easy way to symbolize
it you know as
a baby but it's also a baby that doesn't
act like a regular baby like it won't
eat
uh it's you know it has those like
[ __ ] sores all over it and he's like
you are sick that's [ __ ] cracks me up
i don't know why
but um you know so and then the fact
that
it doesn't um i mean he just kind of
leaves it by itself although it seems
like it cries all the time nobody ever
picks it up
um it's just like a head and when he
cuts open the bandages
at the end it's like it doesn't have any
skin it's just guts like it's just guts
inside so like you said it's
you know it yes it's a baby in the sense
that that's a very easy metaphor for
oh you know i'm saddled with this being
that i have to take care of now it just
represents like responsibility and like
he's not ready for it
um which is also very symbolized very
neatly by
if you noticed in in his uh in his
apartment like right by the
mushroom cloud picture on the wall
there's a
a plant or it's not really a plant but
it's like a branch with like a dead
plant
and it's like in a pile of dirt but it's
not in a pot
and i think that maybe that might
symbolize that he can't even take care
of a [ __ ] plant
so how is he gonna take care of another
person
you know what i'm saying because it's
just kind of like because when he has
the dream sequence later with the baby
head like popping out of his suit or
whatever
which like i said i think that's a
pretty standard anxiety
thing for you know oh i have kids now my
kids are going to replace me
or i'm not me anymore and now i'm just
you know the parent of this child
you know what i mean because your kids
replace you you die and they
continue living usually that's how that
works out but so i think that's what
that means but in that dream sequence
the you know the pile of dirt plant that
was next to his bed
is big and it comes like out on the
stage like on this little rolling
dolly or whatever so as i said i think
that symbolizes like his
lack of nurturance or his just his lack
of ability to take care of something
besides himself
you know what i'm saying so i think
that's all it is i think it's just like
a
a nightmarish fever dream about
anxieties about not being able to
take care of taking take any
responsibility
you know what i mean especially for like
you know a wife or a baby or whatever it
is you're just like afraid of adulthood
you're afraid of all the
responsibilities that are going to come
with it
um so i think that's all that's all that
is i think but um you know
your your mileage may vary like i said
but i'd be interested to know if anybody
else has any uh
interpretations especially the lady the
radiator i think she's angel of death i
think
that she's she's but she's his release
because
once he gets rid of the baby and the
baby's head comes back like really big
and like starts flashing everything so
he realizes by killing the baby he's
only made the problem even worse so then
he feels like the only release now is
death
um so he goes and to be with the lady in
the radiator and she's like yeah he did
the good thing it's like you know
everything's fine now um but as i said
there are
more optimistic uh interpretations of
that so i'd be interested to see if
anyone's got any
but uh you know like it's not it's
nothing's wrong
you know none of the interpretations are
wrong because you can kind of like read
whatever you wanted to it but i have
more of like a pessimistic
uh reading of it i guess that was just
the vibe i got
and i think too it's instructive to if
you haven't seen eraserhead for a long
time
it's almost kind of like i don't know i
don't know if i'd say this
necessarily i don't know if eraserhead
is the best david lynch to start with if
you haven't seen it
i think it's better to like watch some
of his later [ __ ] because
then you'll get a sense of his
world and his proclivities and the way
he goes about things the way he uses
symbols
and so i think that if you see something
like
uh you know if you watch twin peaks or
if you want mulholland drive or
something like that and then you go back
and watch eraserhead i think eraserhead
will seem a lot more straightforward
um you know once you get a sense of like
where he's coming from because he uses a
lot of the same
themes and tropes and symbols across a
lot of his work because he has like a
lot of the same
obsessions i guess so so sometimes
it it's helpful to see some of his newer
stuff and then go back and watch his
older stuff and it seems a lot more
clear
um that said i'd be really really happy
if someone
would talk to me about inland empire
because i think that might be the only
movie of his that i haven't
entirely figured out yet you know what i
mean there's some parts of that that
i've kind of figured out but then some
parts i'm just kind of like still
working on
uh but i need to see it again but i
don't you know it's like three and a
half hours long
so it's kind of a time commitment but um
you know
so uh as always let's continue the
discussion
down in the comments because any other
david lynch people out there i want to
hear what you have to say about this
movie and about any of his other movies
uh because you know how dorky i am about
that [ __ ] as i said on my mulholland
drive review
and uh that'll do it for this movie
retrospective
we will see you on the next one bye